the CBS series NCIS is America's most
watched drama on TV it follows a
fictional team of military investigators
that delves into criminal cases
involving members of the Navy and Marine
Corps starting tomorrow 48 hours takes
an in-depth look at the several real
NCIS cases that agents cannot forget the
first episode focuses on a murdered
sailor
her husband and the dead man found in
the bedroom I've seen horror films I've
seen on the other slasher films when I
walked in my first reaction and I
remember thinking oh my god and this is
real
Dennis Santos is an NCIS investigator
but back in 1996 he was a sergeant with
a Virginia Beach police NCIS Special
Agent Brian Ricardo joined Santos at the
scene two sailors were dead once he
brown and Elise Makdessi
we're coworkers assigned to the Oceana
base headquarters Elise Makdessi was a
good sailor she was a model sailor
Elise's husband Eddie told investigators
Quincy Brown ambushed the couple when
they returned home from dinner
knocking Eddie unconscious I'm on the
phone with the police the whole time I'm
like I'm saying please get here fast
when Eddie came to he says he saw Quincy
Brown stabbing his wife Quincy Brown is
in her apartment and Quincy Brown has
been shot dead while murdering Elise
shot by Elise's husband Eddie before we
even left the crime scene that night we
had discovered a videotape
[Music]
Elise Makdessi spoke from the grave to
say what had happened to her reporter
Mike Mather covered the story from the
very beginning late this was a very big
story Elise Makdessi was dead it was a
big deal at the time on the video police
said she had been sexually harassed on
the job we knew that it was our duty to
conduct a thorough investigation into
her allegations we had to speak for
Elise it would take the worldwide reach
of NCIS agents to reveal the true motive
behind a diabolical case of murder the
crime scene the more we thought about it
appeared to be staged this is the story
of no murder case spanning six years and
too confident the more that I got
involved and learning about Quincy and
learning about Elise Makdessi that I
said we need justice for them
[Music]
justice is right after rocky Carroll
plays the director of the NCIS on the
scripted show and you just heard his
voice narrating the new six-part series
48 hours NCIS he joins us at the table
I'll say I know you watch the show in
it's real TV show real TV show because
that case that actual real case sounds
like it could have been one of your
scripts on NCIS but this was a real
thing this was a real thing and so I'm
branching out a little bit I'm going
from the world of make-believe although
most of our cases that we cover on the
show are based on real cases but now we
have this this 6 episode series of real
NCIS cases and I've been given the honor
of being the narrator and you think
those people watch NCIS will want to see
this kind of thing because it'd be even
more interesting because they can see
yeah and you know I have a few of those
in my home my wife who loves 48 hours
the sort of news magazine shows like
that the sort of unsolved mysteries it
seems that they can't get enough of that
so I'm hoping that the the NCIS fans
those who watch our show every Tuesday
night will we'll follow up and we'll
want to have more of it so it's so
fascinating to be able to hear the
actual NCIS agents in the 48 hours piece
how did they feel about retelling their
story you know in the nine seasons not
good now that I've been a part of this
this great franchise and I've had
chances to go to some of the NCIS
headquarters meet with the agents sit in
the real directors office and talk to
them we get nothing but positive
feedback they love the fact that the
show because what what our motto always
is is that the star of the show is the
agency and we try to put the agency in
its best light and I guess the proof is
when we meet the real agents and we meet
the real people of NCIS and their
response is so warm and they thank us
for what they do and how we have we
brought up recruitment nobody asks them
what NCIS stands for anymore so a lot of
them are former military and there's
just their service to their country
their continued service to their country
the thing that drives them to the search
for truth the search for answers and
that's what we try to portray on our
series and I think that's what people
are
connected to because I've been asked
over and over what's what's the form of
house why is this show so successful
after 14 see I said if I could if I knew
that answer I'd bottle it and sell it
but it there is there was something
innately about the sense of purpose that
these people have that is infectious to
the viewer I think this is awesome and
you're part of the now CBS family part
of the CBS activity
rocky Carroll it's called 48 hours NCIS
it premieres tomorrow night at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS